Je suis la première personne à être seule sur une
planète entière Marquer Watney est
accidentellement abandonné sur Mars Il
réalise que la seule façon de sortir
d'ici Il va parcourir 3 200
kilomètres pour
rejoindre le véhicule de retour Je dois vivre pendant 50
jours à l'intérieur d'un  Rover avec un support de plongée marginal de
la taille d'une petite camionnette,
donc face à des chances écrasantes, il ne me
reste qu'une seule option, je vais devoir faire de
la science, il a un
voyage épique pour se rendre à son point de
départ  et il doit déchirer les deux
véhicules pour créer un véhicule dur à cuire
qui peut se rendre de l'autre
côté de Mars,
notre conception Rover est tout-terrain basée sur
un véhicule agricole avec
direction intégrale et suspension intégrale, mais
n'a pas d'essieu traditionnel  à cause du
sol, donc les roues doivent pouvoir le
faire indépendamment, nous avons pensé que
c'était un avantage, il y a un
véhicule photo fonctionnel qui va
en fait rouler sur un terrain très
semblable à la surface de Mar  s sur les déserts
d'eau rond et jouer
pour une vraie personne de travail dans whoo-hoo
peut-être que la NASA pourrait prendre la page sur un
livre de design car ils disent généralement qu'ils
regardent des films ou de nouvelles idées plus rapidement,
mieux nous aimons ce genre de choses,
je pense qu'ils ne le font pas  dire pouvons-nous avoir un
brevet qui sort là-bas